the view from a helicopter of
australia's inferno
bushfires on fraser island have been
burning for seven weeks
they've destroyed half of the unesco
listed world heritage site
now people living in the town of happy
valley have been told to leave as the
fires close in
look we're um preparing for the worst
you know type of thing and we're going
to try to hit with
everything we've got today we're pulling
out all stops
we're trying to stop this fire impacting
on that happy valley township
as well as managing the other numerous
fires that are currently blazing across
fraser island
the blaze was sparked by an illegal
campfire
but it's been fueled by high winds
record low rainfall and record high
temperatures
it's been a warm day been a tough tough
day when it comes to firefighting
and we have been devoting significant
resources to fighting the fire
on fraser island yeah spot fires galore
down here
a public inquiry into australia's
devastating bushfires last year said the
conditions that created them were
unprecedented and warned they may become
more common
it was the country's hottest and driest
year on record
and the fires burned about 350 square
kilometers of land
[Applause]
many blame climate change but
australia's prime minister has rejected
calls to cut dependence on coal
and take more action on global warming
the authorities on fraser island say
mobile phone coverage
power and water services might soon be
cut off
despite the dangers some people are
staying behind to defend their homes
victoria gatenby al jazeera well we can
now speak to professor mark howden he is
the director of the climate change
institute at australian national
university and he joins us now from
canberra
professor hardin thank you for being
with us i understand you're also a vice
chair of the intergovernmental panel
on climate change and i believe you've
also been involved in scenario mapping
so you're very well placed indeed to
tell us about the trends that we're
looking at here
how much of what's happening right now
is expected
well uh good evening anastasia
what we're seeing is very much uh
according to the playbook of climate
change
we've been expecting these sorts of
changes for decades now
uh they're increasingly coming to
fruition and increasingly what we're
seeing
is climate change is embedded in each of
these events
so it's not a question of whether this
would occur with or without climate
change it's just that climate change is
ramping up
these events when they happen well we've
been watching these climate risks grow
and perhaps
with the fires in australia and
california awareness is growing too
are you optimistic do you think about
the speed of change when it comes to
political will here
i think we do need to accelerate if
we're to avoid the worst of climate
change
and that's what the intergovernmental
panel on climate change said
uh that we really only have a handful of
years if we're to reduce our emissions
in a way that can reduce
uh the uh temperature going up and
prevent it going up by more than one and
a half degrees
we're already around about 1.1 degree
above pre-industrial levels and at the
moment we're tracking towards three
degrees
so the sorts of changes we'd expect at
three degrees far
exceed the worst case scenarios we're
seeing right now
well this has been a bit of a strange
year i guess to say the least and it
feels like when
covert hit we were really just beginning
to see momentum build around a climate
conversation
has the pandemic do you think distracted
us from the climate crisis or
or is this a potential opportunity for
change
look i tend to look on the bright side
and i think it is a great opportunity
for change
and not just that we've already reduced
our greenhouse emissions this year
quite significantly because of the
lockdown but what it's shown is we can
act
very quickly um and very decisively if
we need to
uh and also we it's shown that we can
take scientific advice on board with
very large-scale decisions
and lastly i think it's shown that we
can operate as a continuum from
individuals through to governments and
so we can actually operate as a society
in the way that's needed if we're to
address climate change well speaking of
action professor it'll
have been what five years this week that
the paris agreement was negotiated
and it felt like that really spurred a
shift in the way that governments and
particularly businesses invested in the
green economy is that continuing given
the current economic context at the
speed that it needs to
i think we're seeing more and more
governments coming on board and more and
more big companies coming on board
and a swing in public opinion in terms
of climate change
and they all add up to prospects for
action so we're not seeing that
coming through in terms of our
greenhouse gas emissions but i think
it's the necessary start of that change
and we were talking about covert before
and i think what we're seeing
increasingly is discussions about
how a recovery post covered could
actually build in some of the good
things that we need to have
not just to address climate change but
to address many other issues such as
inequity
professor mark howden there the director
of the climate change institute
at anu a very optimistic professor
thanks very much for joining us here on
al jazeera mr hardin
thanks nastasia